[موسيقى]
في الحرب ليست كل دروبي متاحه فهناك طرق
عليك اجتنابها
[موسيقى]
سلاح الجو الامريكي اعلن بدء العمل على
خطط لتطوير القاذفه الشهيره ب 52 لتتمكن
من البقاء في الخدمه حتى عام 2050
الترقيات الجديده ستشترك فيها شركه رولز
رويس وبوي وستشمل الخطه التي من المنتظر
اعتمادها قبل نهايه العام الحاليه استبدال
محركات القاذفه الامريكيه الاشهر في سلاح
الجو بمحرك من طراز اف 130 بتكلفه تصل الى
نحو مليارين و600 مليون دولار
صفقه جديده بين شركه البستانس والقوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه بقيمه 180 مليون دولار
لتدريب الطيارين على طائرات اف 16 حيث
ستوفر الشركه مراكز تدريب ومحاكاه
للطيارين الاسرائيليين للتعلم على كيفيه
التعامل مع جميع الاسلحه الحاليه وكذلك
ايضا في بيئات القتال المختلفه من المنتظر
ان يتم تسليم مراكز التدريب خلال ثلاث
سنوات كما تضمن العقد خدمات التشغيل
والصيانه لمده 15 سنه اضافيه
رصد تقرير وانشطه الفضاء السنوي لعام 2022
تخطي الصين لروسيا في عدد الاقمار
الصناعيه والتي تم اطلاقها خلال العام
الماضي وكذلك احتلال الصين للمركز الثاني
عالميا بعد الولايات المتحده التقرير الذي
اعده جون فان ماكدويل عالم الفيزياء
الفلكيه في مركزي هارفارد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للفيزياء الفلكيه اشار
الى تخطي الصين لامريكا وروسيا في عدد
الاقمار المخصصه لمهام دفاعيه حيث تملك
الصين 45 قمرا لاغراض دفاعيه مقابل ثلاثين
للولايات المتحده و15 روسيا التقرير حارس
ايضا على الاشاره الى احتماليه امتلاك
الصين عددا اكبر من الاقمار التي تعمل
لاغراض عسكريه بسبب تعقيم بكين وحرصها على
سريه معلوماتها
لا تزال صناعه المنظومات المسيره تشهد
عمليات تطوير بهدف زياده قدرتها وفعاليتها
سواء في جانب صناعه المسيرات او المنظومات
المضاده لها شركه اندرال الامريكيه اشتهرت
مؤخرا كونها واحده من الشركات المنتجه
لمسيرات بريه وجويه وكذلك بحريه وايضا
منظومات مضاده لطائرات المسيره للوقوف
اكثر على احدث منتجات الشركه ودورها في
هذا المجال معنا في الاستوديو رئيس مكتب
الشركه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط السيده جون
ماكدونالدز اولا مستر جون اهلا بك معنا
وشكرا على وجودك معنا في اهل الاستوديو
مستر جون الكثير من المسيارات موجوده في
الاسواق اليوم لكن ما الذي يميز المسيرات
التي تقدمها شركه اندرويد
سواء اندرس
بتطوير البرمجيات وليس المعدات فنحن شركه
برمجيات مدعومه بالمعدات لدينا افضل
مهندسين البرمجيات من شركات اوكولوس وسبيس
اكس ومايكروسوفت والافضل في جنوب
كاليفورنيا نحن نستخدم الحوسبه المتقدمه
اي ان المعلومات لا تعود الى كمبيوتر كبير
مما يتسبب في بطء العمليه بل المعددات
فيها رقاقه الكمبيوتر مثل تلك الموجوده في
هاتفك وتقوم باغلب العمل على المعدات مما
يقلل المعلومات العائده الى الشخص المسؤول
في حلقه اتخاذ القرار ولقد قررنا ان الشخص
المسؤول في حلقه اتخاذ القرار هو الاسلوب
الصحيح للقيام بالعمل اي ان الانسان يبقى
له الاثر والقدره وفي نفس الوقت اخرجناه
من الحلقه لاننا اردنا ان تقوم البرمجيات
بالعمل وبلا شكل لا نريد ان يكون هناك شخص
خارج حلقه اتخاذ القرار فالانسان دائما
موجود في هذه الحلقه لقد تعاونا مع افضل
شركات التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ذات الخبره في
العالم فنحن لا نبني محركات المروحيات ولا
نبني شفرات المروحيات نحن ناخذ من افضل
الشركات وبافضل قيمه ثم نجمعها مع
برمجياتنا من اجل المضيق قدما بسرعه كبيره
جدا مثال على ذلك كم هو عمرها هاتفك عام
واحد نعم اذا اخر تحديث تلقائي كان ربما
قبل بضعه اسابيع نفس الشيء ينطبق على
البرمجيات حيث نقوم بتحديثها بشكل دوري
واسرع بكثير من قدره المقتنيات الدفاعيه
السابقه وبالتالي فالدينا اسلوب مختلف
للحصول على برمجيتنا وهو عن طريق الاشتراك
الذي يشبه اشتراكك بخدمات الهاتف السنويه
مما يحافظ على تحديث البرمجيات بشكل مستمر
اذا تحديث المستمر هو اهم يميز مسيراتكم
في شركه اندرال لكن فيما يتعلق بالمنظومات
الاعتراضيه للطائرات المسيره انتم اعتمدتم
في التقنيه التي تقدمونها على مسيره
اعتراضيه ضد المسيره العاديه لماذا هذه
التقنيه بالضبط وما الذي يميز هذه التقنيه
عن غيرها من التقنيات المضاده او
المنظومات الاعتراضيه للمسيرات بشكل عام
ويجلس السؤال
قررنا تطبيق العلوم والفيزياء ليس فقط مع
البرمجيات فعلينا ان نتذكر انه خلال
القيام بعمليه مكافحه المسجلات فلدينا وقت
قصير جدا الاعتراضها لذلك طورنا اسرع
مسيله ممكنه وتذكر ان المسير التي تحلق
باتجاه هنا حجمها يساوي حجم الحمامه ومن
الصعب جدا اكتشافها ولذلك لدينا رادارات
جيده جدا مركبه على ابراج وترسل مسيراتنا
الى ذلك الاتجاه وبعد ذلك تهاجم من الاسفل
الى الاعلى والسبب وراء ذلك هو ان الحوسبه
المتقدمه جدا في الرادار قدرتها كبيره في
استكشاف السماء ورؤيه الهدف بشكل كامل من
دون اي معوقات من الارض لذلك طبقنا
العلومه لتجاوز بعض نقاط ضعف التكنولوجيا
وكذلك لتقليل الاضرار الجانبيه الناجمه عن
الانفجار لان مسافه اعتراض الهدف ستكون
على بعد كيلومتر ونصف منا وسيسقط الخطام
في المنطقه القريبه واخر ما يميز هذه
القدرات هو دقه النجاح في التخلص من الهدف
التي تبلغ
98% حسب تقييم الوكاله الامريكيه خارج
شركاتنا طيب فيما يتعلق بمستقبل صناعه
المنظومات المسيره بشكل عام مستر جون الان
هناك الكثير من الشركات التي تعتمد على
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي اين انتم في
اندريل من الاعتماد على هذه التقنيه
سوداء
الامر
التالينا واخلاقيتنا فتخيل كل الاشياء
التي يمكن للمسيره ان تقوم بها والتي لم
تكن ممكنه في السابق بسبب الكلفه مثل كل
الصور الجميله التي نحصل عليها من
المسلسلات والاستكشافات التي توصلنا اليها
الان ولم نتمكن من تحقيقها في الماضي بسبب
عدم قدرتنا على التحليق الى تلك الاماكن
او لانها كانت مكلفه جدا مثال على استخدام
هذه المسيارات هو في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ للوصول الى الاوديه العميقه في
جبال الامارات
والعمل الذي يستغرق الاشخاص اياما للقيام
به يستغرق دقائق او ساعات الانجازه
باستخدام التكنولوجيا ومسيلاتنا الذاتيه
مؤخرا ارسلت احدى مسيراتنا الخاصه بعمليات
الاستطلاع بعيده المدى الى اعصار ايان في
الولايات المتحده لان طائره هانتر المخصصه
للاعاصير تضررت كثيرا واعيدت الى القاعده
لذلك اطلقوا المسيرته وتمكنوا من تحمل
رياح بسرعه
155 ميلا في الاعصار ويتمكنت من القيام
بما لم تتمكن اي طائره من القيام به
والتكنولوجيا مكنه الخبراء من التعرف على
اتجاه الاعصار مما اسهم في انقاذ الارواح
لانهم حضروا السكان وطلبوا منهم الابتعاد
عن مسار الاعصار
فيما يتعلق يعني وجود شركه اندرول في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط انت رئيس مكتب الشركه
مستر جون هنا في هذه المنطقه اولا كيف
تقيمون شركاتكم وتعاونكم مع دول منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وكذلك ما هي الدول التي
تعتمد على المنظومات التي تقدمونها في هنا
في المنطقه
الولايات المتحده ونحن منفتحون لتقديم
التكنولوجيا عجل بارزه الى المنطقه حيث
يكون ذلك مناسبا تذكر انه من بين اهم
ثلاثه اولويات الشركائنا وحلفائنا في
المنطقه هو اولويتان هما مكافحه المسيرات
الجويه ومكافحه تهذيب البشر والمخدرات
التي بدات تتزايد في كل هذه الدول وعلى
سبيل المثال نحن منشغلون على حدودنا
الجنوبيه الشرقيه مع 200 برجا فقط شيدنا
جدارا افتراديا في جنوب شرق الولايات
المتحده ومراقبه الحدود والجمارك قبضوا
على اربعه اضعاف الاشخاص الذين قبضوا
عليهم في العام الماضي جزء من ذلك يعود
لاعاده استخدام القوه البشريه والقوه
البشريه في الشرق الاوسط محدوده ولذلك
يمكننا الان استخدمه هذه القوه البشريه
بكفاءه اعلى وترك العمل للالام مما يترك
المجال للبشر لايجاد الحلول لتلك
الاولويتين وبين خفر السواحل والشرطه وامن
الحدود نحن باشياء كثيره هنا في الشرق
الاوسط ونحن متحمسون لوجودنا هنا شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا وعلى كل ما تفضلت به
من توضيحات مصر جون ماكدونالد رئيس مكتب
شركه اندرول الامريكيه هنا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
تركيا التي تمكنت من اقتحام عالمي صناعه
السلاح مؤخرا هذا بحكم موقعها الجغرافيه
وما تمتلكه من شركات حكوميه وخاصه نافذه
في هذا المجال باتت تسع مؤخرا الى تعزيز
دفاعاتها البحريه بصناعه محليه هذا بعد
تجربه ناجحه على منظومه دفاعا بحريه
منظومه
هذه المنظومه التي تصنعها شركه روكيت سان
التركيه تتكون من رادار ونظمته قياده
وسيطره وتعقب للاهداف وتوجيه للنيران
ذاتيه الحركه وكذلك بطاريات صواريخ متنقله
كما سيتم دمج هذه المنظومه مع نظام
ادفانتا لاداره المعارك لتحديد نوع الهدف
والصاروخ المناسب للتصدي اليهود المنظومه
لديها القدره على اطلاق نوعين من الصواريخ
الاول من طراز شاكر المضاد للسفن هذا
الصاروخ يصل مداح حتى 150 كيلو مترا مع
راس حربيه ي حتى 70 كجم اما الثاني فهو من
طراز كارا اتانغا المضاد للسفن او الاهداف
البريه والذي يصل مداح حتى 2008 كيلومترا
مع راس حربيه يزنوا ماتين 250 كلغراما
بعد الفاصل قائد القوات الجويه الامريكيه
بالقياده المركزيه يوضح ابرز تهديدات التي
تواجه الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وخرا بدا من الحرب على بقايا تنظيم
داعش في سوريا والعراق وصولا للتصدي
لتهديدات التي تشكلها الميليشيات المواليه
لايران
منطقه الخليج شهدت تحليل قاذفات به 52
الامريكيه في رساله اعتبرها مراقبون
تحذيرا امريكيا مباشره لايران هذا طبعا
بالاضافه الى مناورات امريكيه اسرائيليه
خدمت نفس الهدف للوقوف على دور القوات
الجويه الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
معنا الفريق اليكسيس جرينكو قائد القوات
الجويه بالقياده المركزيه الامريكيه اولا
يعني فريق جرين كوتش برايك ما هو التهديد
الاهم والاكبر الذي يواجه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط في هذه المرحله
هذا
سؤال
من وجهه نظر فان اغلب المشكلات المرتبطه
بانعدام الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط نبيعه
من دوله واحده وللاسف هذه الدوله هي ايران
ايران لديها مجموعه من الوكلاء والشركاء
في المنطقه وتوفر لهم المساعدات الفتاكه
ويستغلون هذه الشبكه لبث الفوضى عبر منطقه
الشام والخليج العربي ولمهاجمه اغلب
الشركائنا في مجلس التعاون الخليجي للاسف
غالبا ما يكون المصدر هو النظام الايراني
ونشاطاتهم خلال سعيهم ليكون القوه
المهيمنه في المنطقه
اشتركتم مؤخرا في تدريبات جويه مع القوات
الاسرائيليه ويعني وصفها البعض بانها
رساله امريكيه اسرائيليه مباشره لايران
لكن على الجانب الاسرائيلي اسرائيل تؤكد
مرا كان حتميه التوجيه ضربه عسكريه مباشره
لمنشات ايران نوويه انتم في القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه تتفقون مع اسرائيل حول
وجهه النظر هذه ام لا
شك ان البرنامج النووي الايراني يسبب
القلق لكل من يعيش ويعمل في المنطقه
والمهام الموكله اليه هي ضمان الجهوزيه
وتوفير الخيارات المحتمله لردع الايرانيين
والاستجابه لاي تهديد النابع من حصولهم
على سلاح النووي وهذا الامر لا يقلق
امريكا واسرائيل فحسب بل يخلق كل دول
المنطقه واعتقد ان اغلب الشركائنا في
المنطقه يتشاركون وجهه نظر حول ذلك حيث ان
الحصول على سلاح النووي سيكون كارثيا
للمنطقه وسيتسبب في زعزعتها بشكل اكبر
ونحن نعمل بشكل اساسي عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه والطرق الاخرى في محاوله لمنع
الايرانيين من الحصول على مثل هذا السلاح
دمج اسرائيل مؤخرا ضمن التحالفات العسكريه
لواشنطن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كان احد
الادوار على عاتق القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه اين وصلتم في هذا الامر وعلى
الجانب الاخر ما هو ما هي الخطوات التي تم
اتخاذها لتحقيق هذا الدمج على ارض الواقع
سنفور
لدمج اسرائيل في القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه هو الاتفاق الابراهيمي حيث فتح
ابواب التعاوني مع الجيش الاسرائيلي عبر
المنطقه
الاسرائيليون حالهم حالو العديد من الدول
الاخرى لديهم جيش متقدم جدا ويتكون وجهات
النظر الخاصه بالتهديدات مع بقيه شركائنا
في منطقه مسؤوليات القياده المركزيه وانا
ارى انه كل ما زاد عدد الدول في المنطقه
التي تخاطب اسرائيل حول تهديدات المشتركه
التي تواجهنا جميعا وبشكل خاص من ايران
اصبح وضعه لمنطقه افضل وهو مصدر الاستقرار
لدمج اسرائيل بشكل متكامل في الهيكليه
الامنيه الموضوعه منذ سنوات
نمره الجيران كوتش الى اي مدى تعتمدون على
الطائرات المسيره في العمليات التي تنفذها
اا تنفذونها في هذه المنطقه خاصه في هذه
المرحله التي اعلن فيها عن تشكيل الكثير
من القوات وكذلك الوحدات الخاصه لمكافحه
تهريب الاسلحه وتجاره المخدرات ومثل هذه
الامور التي تهدد امن المنطقه بشكل كامل
عددا كبيرا من المسيرات واغلب التي
نستخدمها في عملياتنا هي طائرات نتحكم بها
عن بعد ام كيو تسعه ونحنون نستخدمها لعده
اغراض في المنطقه وكما ذكرت واغلب
استخداماتنا لها خاصه بمكافحه الجماعات
المتطرفه العنيفه وهذه المسيرات تزودنا
بالقدره على مراقبه المناطق التي تشهدون
نشاطات داعش او الجماعات المتطرفه الاخرى
وقدرته هذه المسايرات على التحليق فوق تلك
المناطق لفترات طويله
جدا في هذا السياق نحن في القوه الجويه
التاسعه نسعى لتوسيع استخدام التكنولوجيا
غير الماهوله والرقميه فمن ناحيه امن
الحدود ومراقبه نشاطات التهريب فان مثل
هذه المنصات التي تحمل المجسات وبامكانها
تحليق لفترات طويله تمثل اداه مهمه للغايه
فريق جرين كوتش يعني انت مؤخرا قمت بزياره
عدد من دول المنطقه لكن على المستوى
العسكري كيف تقيم القدرات الدفاعيه التي
تمتلكها دول المنطقه خاصه في التعامل مع
التهديد الذي تشكله الطائرات المسيره او
الصواريخ البالسيه
[موسيقى]
سؤال الممتاز الدول التي تتعامل مع هذه
التهديدات منذ فتره طويله تعلمت كيفيه
التعامل معها ونحن في القوه الجويه
الامريكيه نتعلم منهما واستطيع ان اقول لك
ان شبكه الاكتشاف والقدره على اطلاق
الطائرات المقاتله لاعتراض المسايرات
القادمه واداء قدرات الدفاع الصاروخي لدى
العديد من الدول من شركائنا مدهشه حقا
ولذلك فان تعاون الذي نشهده عبر الحدود
بين الدول المصالح المشتركه ضد هذه
التهديدات التي تقدم بشكل اساسي الى شركاء
ايران مثل الحوثيين في اليمن فهذه
الامكانات واعده جدا لجمع الدولي ذات
المصالح المشتركه لان تعمل جنبا الى جانبه
مع القوه الجويه التاسعه الامريكيه وفيما
بينها من اجل مكافحه هذه التهديدات ولكن
هؤلاء الشركاء يعلموننا اشياء جديده
في كل يوم حول كيفيه مواجهتها هذه
التهديدات
جنرال جرين كوتش مؤخرا بات هناك تعاون
عسكري بين الصين وبعض دول المنطقه هل
لديكم مخاوف في القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه من هذا التعاون او تنامي
التعاون العسكري ما بين الصين وما بين بعض
دول المنطقه
اعتقد ان ايران لديها علاقه صفقات مع هذه
الدول بينما تبني الولايات المتحده شركات
عميقه وطويله قائمه على مصالحنا
الاستراتيجيه لان الصين لديها مصالح
اقتصاديه ترغب باستغلالها مثل بعض المصادر
الهيدروكربونيه الموجوده
في التوغل في افريقيا او ربما لبيع بعض
معداتهم العسكريه ولا توجد شراكه حقيقيه
واودوا ان اذكره اذا سمحت لي الصينيون
كنديهم حضور في القرن الافريقي منذ فتره
طويله ومع ذلك لاتذكر مره واحده قام فيها
الصينيون باعتراض ايه مساعدات فتاكه تتدفق
من ايران الى احد وكلائهم او قواتهم
الشركه التي تهدد احد دول الخليج في
الصينيون ربما يكونون موجودين هنا الا
انهم ليست لديهم اي رغبه في التعاون او
مشاركه المعلوماتيه فهم فقط يخدمون
المصالح الصينيه خلال وجودهم هنا الجنرال
جرين كويتش ما بين الحين والاخر تظهر بعض
الخلافات او التباينات في المواقف
السياسيه ما بين البيت الابيض والاداره
الامريكيه وبعض دول المنطقه لكن على
المستوى العسكري هل يتاثر التعاون العسكري
ما بين واشنطن وما بين بعض الدول المنطقه
بسبب بعض الخلافات السياسيه
العلاقه العسكريه بيننا وبين كل شريك
اساسين في المنطقه قويه للغايه وبين ما
تتقلب العلاقات السياسيه حسب الاختلافات
السياسيه او التوفق السياسي استطيع ان
اؤكد لكم ان التعاون العسكري يبقى مستقرا
ومستمرا وهناك شركات وصداقات وكل ذلك يوفر
الاستقرار الكبير للمنطقه وانا فخور جدا
بقدرتنا على العمل باستمرار مع شركائنا
على الصعيد العسكري بغض النظر عن ما يجري
في المجالس السياسي فريق اليكسيس جرين
كويتش قائد القوات الجويه بالقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا على وجودك
معنا
[موسيقى]
شكلت منذ دخولها الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مصدر القلق الاول لتيارين الامريكيين
المقاتله اليابانيه ميتسوبيشي اي 600 هذه
المقاتله التي اشتهرت بين الطيارين في
القوات الامريكيه بالاسم زيرو دخلت
المقاتله ميتسوبيشي الى الخدمه في العام
1940 اعتبرت حينها اقوى المقاتلات
الهجوميه هذا بسبب قدرتها الكبيره في
المناوره وكذلك تحليقها لمدى بعيد يصل الى
1870 كلم اول عملياتها العسكريه كانت في
الحرب الصينيه
حيث تمكنت اليابان بفضل هذه المقاتله من
تحقيق سيطره جويه لفتره مهمه من الحرب كما
شاركت ايضا بالهجوم الشهير على ميناء بيرن
هاربر الامريكي والحقت اضرار جزيلا
بالقوات الامريكيه الموجوده في الميناء في
هذا الوقت
تميزت ايضا المقاتله ميتسوبيشي اي 600
بقدرات الناريه كبيره حيث كانت مسلحه
بمدفعين رشاشين ثقيلين من عيار 20 مليمتر
وكذلك مدفعين اخرين من عيار 7.7 ملم هذا
بجانب قدرتها على حمل قنبلتين كل قنبله
تزن نحو 60 كجمرا لكن في اواخر يعني
1943 بدات موازين القوى تتغير لصالح
الحلفاء هذا بعد تمكن الشركات الامريكيه
من تطوير مقاتلات اسرع واقوى هذا الامر
افقد مقاتله الزيرو قوتها ورفع مستوى
خسائرها بشكل كبير الى ان خرجت من الخدمه
نهائيا في عام 1945
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكريه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]